نعم على سبيل المثال الحقائق التي اظهرتها
دراسات الثلاث التي
نشرت في يوم التاسيس السعودي 1444
اثبتت التاريخ الحقيقي للدوله السعوديه
1139 اثبتت ان الدوله السعوديه الاولى
نشات على مجموعه من القيم المجتمعيه ذات
الطابع الامني الامني الامني حيث ان
المجتمع في نجد والجزيره العربيه انذاك
كان يعاني من حاله من التفكك الاجتماعي
والاقتصادي والسياسي بسبب بغياب او غياب
وجود حكم مركز قوي يكون قادر على فرض
الامن والاستقرار الاجتماعي وحفظ امن طرق
قوافل الحج والتجاره والسابله فهذا الامر
الامام محمد بن سعود رحمه الله من خلال
موروثه السياسي العريق والذي يمتد الى سنه
850 للهجره على زمن جده من على مريضه الذي
اسس حكمه السياسي في الدرعيه ادرك هذه
الحقيقه التاريخيه بانه يتوجب عليه بناء
حكم سياسي قوي يقوم على فرض الامن